vamos a hacer un panorama de lo que es
la glucólisis que por cierto es una ruta
de reacciones bioquímicas muy importante
y que ocurre en prácticamente todos los
seres vivos y esencialmente consiste en
tomar la glucosa verdad una molécula de
glucosa como combustible y digamos en
este proceso vamos a tratar de romperla
y además de eso vamos a obtener dos
moléculas de piruvato muy bien entonces
la glucosa es una molécula de 6 átomos
de carbono verdad mientras que los
piruvato tienen tres átomos de carbono
verdad entonces esencialmente ahí es en
donde podemos ver cómo es que se rompe
la molécula de glucosa verdad para
producir por supuesto dos piruvato y en
este proceso vamos a producir también
dos moléculas de atp verdad esto esto es
en realidad una producción neta verdad
porque resulta que necesita
necesitamos digamos emplear dos a tps
para luego producir 4 atp es así que
digamos de forma neta tenemos
dos apps es más vale la pena digamos
escribir esto nosotros utilizamos o
usamos 2 atp es 2 atp pero vamos a
producir verdad nosotros producimos 4
moléculas de atp y entonces de forma
digamos neta vamos a poner el neto
verdad son 2 una ganancia de dos
moléculas de atp entonces en este
proceso también tenemos la reducción de
n además en en el a de h verdad y
recordemos que la reducción
esencialmente es ganar electrones verdad
aquí n además verdad
en realidad n además su nombre digamos
formal sería nicotina de nin de
nucleótido entonces vemos que n además
tiene una carga positiva verdad tiene
una carga positiva pero después de este
otro lado gana un hidrógeno pero pierde
su carga positiva de hecho podríamos
pensar que gana un hidrógeno y un
electrón verdad
podríamos de hecho pensar que en total
lo que ocurre es que gana un hidruro que
sería como un h - verdad los y duros por
supuesto no suelen de ambos deambular
por su cuenta digamos en donde se lleva
a cabo la reacción pero podemos pensar
que digamos en este caso eso es lo que
ocurre verdad así que tiene además gana
un hidrógeno y un electrón extra así que
nuestro n además va a pasar a ser n a dh
y esto por supuesto es un proceso de
reducción aquí esta es una reacción de
reducción por supuesto después en ea de
h se puede oxidar en a lo largo de la
cadena de transporte de electrones y que
de hecho veremos en otro vídeo cuando
hablemos de la fosforilación oxidativa
para poder producir aún más atp muy bien
entonces en resumen tenemos una molécula
de glucosa que tiene 6 átomos de carbono
y vamos a producir dos moléculas de
piruvato verdad que tienen cada uno tres
átomos de carbono también vamos a tener
una producción
de 2 a tps y vamos a poder reducir dos
moléculas de n además en dos moléculas
de nh ahora bien
típicamente la glucólisis es digamos el
inicio de la respiración celular verdad
si contamos con oxígeno alrededor
tendremos que algunos de estos productos
se moverán digamos a la mitocondria
donde se lleva a cabo el ciclo del ácido
cítrico o también conocido como ciclo de
krebs y puede ocurrir la fosforilación
oxidativa si no hubiera oxígeno entonces
se lleva a cabo la respiración anaerobia
es decir digamos la fermentación de la
cual hablaremos en otro vídeo ahora que
ya tenemos en realidad un panorama de lo
que ocurre vamos a adentrarnos con más
detalle a lo que realmente está
ocurriendo en todo este proceso y bueno
un diagrama de todo el mecanismo lo
tengo acá arriba ahí y cuando uno tiene
este tipo de diagrama cesc es sumamente
interesante poderlos apreciar bien en
verdad porque uno puede digamos observar
la complejidad de todo este mecanismo y
que de hecho
ocurriendo en todas tus células en este
preciso momento verdad otra cosa
interesante que podría uno apreciar por
ejemplo es que podría uno preguntarse es
cómo fue que los científicos llegaron a
descubrir todos estos estos procesos que
conforman por ejemplo la glucólisis de
verdad esto sería toda una discusión
bastante fascinante pero bueno aquí solo
vamos a dar una apreciación de las
reacciones químicas que se llevan a cabo
muy bien entonces vamos a empezar
digamos de este lado aquí tenemos la
glucosa verdad vemos que tiene 6 átomos
de carbono 1 2 3 4 5 y 6 verdad y en el
primer paso lo que va a ocurrir es que
se va a fosforila de verdad y de hecho
hay todo un vídeo de cómo es la
fosforilación que ya hemos hecho aquí en
kant academy verdad la fosforilación de
la glucosa y todos los pasos digamos son
facilitados con enzimas verdad en este
caso vamos a utilizar una enzima llamada
exo quinasa verdad y quinasa es digamos
un término general que le damos a las
y que facilitan la fosforilación o la
des fosforilación muy bien entonces las
enzimas buscan disminuir la energía de
activación y la sexo quinasas en
particular van a involucrar iones de
magnesio para poder llevar a cabo esto
ahora otra cosa que hay que observar es
que para poder lograr la fosforilación
utilizamos justamente un atp verdad y
esto es parte digamos de lo que ya hemos
llamado la fase de inversión entonces en
este caso vamos a utilizar un atp y
vamos a estar contando los atp es que se
emplean o que se producen muy bien
entonces ahí tenemos que usamos un atp y
ahora esta reacción por supuesto va a ir
fuertemente de izquierda a derecha
verdad por que fosforila a la glucosa
requiere energía libre pero el atp
libera energía libre verdad y es por eso
que va fuertemente de izquierda a
derecha y solo para que se vea claro que
es lo que está ocurriendo aquí este
hidrógeno va a ser sustituido por este
grupo fosfato que tiene
de este otro lado verdad ahora vamos con
la siguiente reacción esta reacción
también requiere de enzimas está esta
reacción de hecho puede ir en ambas
direcciones verdad aunque lo que tenemos
digamos del lado derecho se está
transformando también a su vez en otros
productos verdad y eso hará que su
concentración disminuya y esta reacción
entonces tenderá a ir
en este sentido verdad y la enzima que
facilita esta reacción es la fósforo
cosa isomerasa muy bien en la foto
glucosa isomerasa que nos va a convertir
glucosa 6 fosfato en fructosa 6 fosfato
y viceversa verdad
de hecho las isomerasa son un tipo
especial de enzimas que nos ayudan a ir
de un isómero a otro que es lo que
ocurre en este caso verdad entonces lo
que va a estar ocurriendo es que este
oxígeno en vez de unirse con este
carbono se va a terminar uniendo con
este otro carbono verdad formando un
ciclo de 5 elementos como lo tenemos de
este lado en lugar de un ciclo de 6 que
teníamos
del lado izquierdo verdad ahora vamos
con la siguiente reacción esta también
va fuertemente en una dirección que es
digamos facilitada también por el atp de
verdad y lo logra en parte por por la
enzima que tenemos aquí que es la
fosforito quinasa muy bien fósforo fruto
quinasa y como usamos un atp puedes
adivinar qué es lo que va a ocurrir
verdad vamos a tomar otro fosfato que
vamos a unir a la fructosa 6 fosfato
verdad entonces digamos este hidrógeno
que teníamos aquí lo vamos a sustituir
completamente por este grupo fosfato que
se encuentra de este otro lado verdad
entonces otra vez se emplea el magnesio
como co factor de nuestra enzima verdad
pues ayuda a estabilizar las cargas
negativas asociadas a los fosfatos pero
lo importante aquí es que nuevamente se
utiliza un atp entonces vamos a tener
que se utiliza
atp y fíjense nada más todo lo que hemos
recorrido es bastante complicado y
bastante complejo pero muy interesante
este proceso verdad de la glucólisis y
es un proceso que está ocurriendo justo
en este momento en en todas las células
de nuestro cuerpo incluso para que yo
pueda hablar pues necesito mover mis
músculos y para eso tiene que ocurrir
una producción de atp es verdad llega y
está involucrada la glucólisis para que
yo pueda hablar en este vídeo así que es
bueno apreciar qué es lo que está
ocurriendo en este momento ahora bien
para el siguiente paso es importante
recordar que la glucólisis esencialmente
se trata de romper la glucosa verdad y
aquí tenemos esta molécula que provino
de la glucosa y ahora está unidad dos
grupos fosfato y en el siguiente paso lo
que vamos a hacer es romperla usando la
enzima fructosa bis fosfato haldol hace
muy bien las enzimas haldol hazas la sal
balanzas facilitan las reacciones haldol
y cash en este caso la reacción al
dólica consiste en romper en dos partes
la molécula que voy a mostrar
aquí aquí están estas dos partes una de
las partes se le conoce como glitter
aldehído 3 fosfato y de hecho éstas
pueden convertirse digamos la una en la
otra con otra isomerasa llamada tríos a
fosfato y eso me da za muy bien entonces
digamos digamos que en este punto de la
glucólisis podemos pensar que tenemos
esencialmente dos glitter aldehídos tres
fosfatos entonces aquí vamos a poner por
dos por dos digamos en realidad tenemos
dos distintas pero ésta puede volver a
convertirse en glitter aldehído tres
fosfato entonces vamos a pensar que
tenemos dos de ellas verdad y de aquí en
adelante hay que imaginar que todos los
pasos ocurren dos veces uno por cada una
de estas moléculas verdad y entonces
tenemos otro paso que también está
facilitado por enzimas verdad aquí
tenemos este otro paso y en este caso
está facilitado por una enzima que
conocemos como deshidrogenasa verdad en
este caso es útil
para reducir n además en nh el nombre de
la enzima completa es literal de ido 3
fosfatos deshidrogenasa y ya hemos
mencionado que el nh se puede utilizar
en la cadena de transporte de electrones
para producir más atp pero en esta
reacción podemos ver que estamos
agregando otro grupo fosfato verdad
estamos agregando un grupo fosfato
verdad sustituyendo este hidrógeno que
teníamos no perdonó este hidrógeno sino
éste hidrógeno que teníamos aquí y bueno
podemos notar que esta reacción puede ir
en ambos sentidos verdad ahora vamos a
pasar a la fase de recompensa verdad
empezamos con con esta molécula que
tiene dos grupos fosfato verdad y con
digamos con esta enzima que conocemos
como fósforo glee cerato quinasa verdad
vamos a remover uno de los grupos
fosfato y en este proceso vamos a
producir uno
atp muy bien entonces en este caso lo
que va a ocurrir es que vamos a producir
una molécula de atp verdad y podríamos
poner un más un atp pero recordemos esto
está ocurriendo dos veces porque tenemos
dos literal de y 23 fosfatos verdad
entonces en realidad lo que vamos a
hacer es agregar 2 atp aquí vamos a
agregar 2 atp y es con el fósforo
literato quinasa que vamos a llegar a
esta otra molécula verdad que ya fue
esencialmente reducir o bueno vamos a
suprimir este grupo fosfato muy bien y
ahora vamos a utilizar la fosforera tomo
taza verdad una muchacha es un tipo de
isomerasa que toma un grupo funcional de
de un sitio y lo pone en otro sitio y
vemos justamente que este grupo fosfato
verdad este este grupo fosfato que
teníamos aquí ahora se va a colocar en
otro sitio que es justamente
la verdad después usamos la en olas a
verdad es otra enzima para poder llegar
a esta molécula que tenemos aquí donde
ahora vamos a utilizar la piruvato
quinasa verdad para poder digamos de
fósforo y la esta molécula y eso nos
lleva finalmente al ácido peer ubicó muy
bien aquí tenemos el ácido peer ubicó
que por supuesto estamos considerando
ácido peer ubicó porque tiene este
hidrógeno de aquí verdad si el hidrógeno
se pierde y el oxígeno se queda con el
electrón entonces tendríamos piruvato
verdad y aquí se considera justamente
como el final de la glucólisis pero
bueno qué fue lo que pasó aquí aquí en
este paso digamos en este justo de aquí
también se produjo atp pero recordemos
que esto pasa dos veces verdad esto pasa
dos veces porque partíamos de dos
moléculas de glitter aldehído tres
fosfato verdad entonces aquí tenemos una
producción
2 atp es también muy bien tenemos una
producción de 2 atp entonces en resumen
tenemos una fase de inversión aquí
tenemos nuestra fase de inversión en
donde hay que utilizar dos moléculas de
atp es verdad en dos partes distintas
pero luego tenemos una fase de
recompensa
tenemos una fase de recompensa en donde
podemos ganar dos a tps en una parte y
luego dos a tps en otra parte así que
espero que todo esto de lo que hablamos
al inicio del vídeo después de haber
visto el mecanismo completo ahora todo
esto cobre sentido